man I'm ready to play  [Music]  it's going to be very challenging but I  think you know for a young team it's a  it's a good opportunity to test  ourselves against some Elite teams how  would you characterize this U.S team  they're very inexperienced on the global  stage together there's a lot of  variability in how they might perform  because of their youth  foreign  [Music]  so what do you want to do about it  you want to stay home and Hammer and  criticize  and say how bad they are  [Music]  thank you  foreign  political things and a lot of other  things that are going on I think that  every country there's no country that's  perfect  I  [Music]  it's a fun group it's a competitive  group I think you can find at least one  person on this team that you can relate  to it's kind of what makes America so  great